en france 24 es hora de hablar de
economía por ello me acompaña en el
estudio mi compañero jorge hurtado jorge
bienvenido iniciamos en cuba porque el
gobierno de miguel díaz canel permitirá
la creación de empresas privadas en la
isla esto sucede por primera vez en más
de 5 décadas los cubanos podrán abrir
pequeñas y medianas empresas privadas
inclusive contratar empleados aunque no
es la primera vez que se intenta estas
son las reformas más significativas que
entrarán en vigencia el 20 de septiembre
los negocios deberán ser aprobados por
el ministerio de economía previamente y
por ejemplo valentín a las firmas o
talleres más pequeños podrán tener desde
1 hasta 10 empleados y los más grandes
inclusive hasta 100 en la isla ha dicho
que se permitirán todas las actividades
menos algunas como la edición de diario
y revistas y las relacionadas al tema de
educación la norma dice que estas pymes
podrán ser además privadas estatales y
mixtas veamos que dicen los economistas
al respecto la gente está buscando
entender comprender el contexto y sobre
todo encontrar oportunidades para
impulsar proyectos que han estado
desarrollando hasta ahora sin un marco
regulatorio favorable
y han podido llevar adelante
precisamente porque no veían espacios
para hacerlo
bueno la reforma llega en medio de una
crisis política el producto interno
bruto retrocedió un 11 por ciento en
2020 y miles de personas protestaron en
julio en rechazo al desabastecimiento y
los cortes de luz y de cuba pasamos a
eeuu porque el presidente anunció
recortes de impuestos para quien aplica
esta política bueno según joe biden el
recorte de impuestos beneficiará a la
clase media y en cambio los aumentará
para los ricos según bailén se estima
que los más ricos que representan el 1%
de los contribuyentes en eeuu evaden
según el 116 mil millones de dólares al
fisco anualmente y prometido destinar
más recursos al servicio de recaudación
de impuestos para frenarlos durante un
discurso desde la casa blanca- bailén
aseguró que el recorte de impuestos era
histórico pero no ofreció detalles al
respecto
recientemente los demócratas de la
cámara de representantes propusieron una
subida de impuestos para las empresas
que ganan más de 5 millones de dólares
al año los demócratas esperan recolectar
2,9 billones de dólares con esa subida
de impuestos durante 10 años y costeará
el gasto social valorado en 3,5 billones
de dólares que el congreso aprobaría a
fin este mes y atravesamos el pacífico
vamos a japón donde las exportaciones
están a la baja
bueno la variante delta y los problemas
en las cadenas de suministro están
afectando las exportaciones japonesas
datos del ministerio de finanzas de ese
país revelan que el crecimiento de las
exportaciones se desaceleró de un 49 por
ciento en junio hasta el 26 por ciento
en agosto esta ralentización se da entre
otras cosas por los bajos envíos de
automóviles por ejemplo toyota motor
anunció la semana pasada de nuevos
recortes de producción por la escasez de
semiconductores que afectarían los
envíos a futuro y podrían tener
consecuencias en las exportaciones de la
tercera mayor economía del mundo jorge y
el foro económico mundial volverá a
davos en 2022 así es
el foro económico mundial fue anunciado
para del 17 al 22 de enero del próximo
año en davos al oeste de suiza desde el
último medio siglo la reunión anual de
davos ha tenido una enorme capacidad
para atraer a los líderes mundiales de
los negocios la política la academia las
artes y la sociedad civil
llevará por lema trabajando juntos
restaurando la confianza para discutir
los estragos que dejó hoy comí 19 el
foro se iba a celebrar en singapur este
año pero la pandemia obligó a los
organizadores a posponer los bueno pues
vuelven los eventos presenciales vamos
con los indicadores de la jornada bueno
wall street cerró este jueves en terreno
mixto debido a las dudas sobre la
recuperación económica en el país y las
pérdidas en las plazas asiáticas en
europa la bolsa española subió este
jueves impulsada por el avance de
inditex y otros valores que
contrarrestaron la caída de wall street
y en américa latina las bolsas cerraron
mixtas con una leve alza de argentina en
medio de su torbellino político por
último cuenta en las cuales la cifra el
día bueno valentina la cifra del día son
700 mil millones de dólares eso es lo
que desembolsó el gobierno de eeuu del
paquete de estímulo de 19 billones de
dólares de esa cantidad de unos 450 mil
millones de dólares fueron destinados a
pagos directos a familias y hogares y
otros 240 mil se dedicaron a dar apoyo
fiscal a los gobiernos estatales locales
y tribales para contra la pandemia e
intentar hacerle acelerar la
recuperación económica por eso usted
muchísimas gracias por esta ampliación a
ustedes por su sintonía recuerden que
pueden ampliar todas las noticias en
nuestra web y continúen con nosotros que
hay más aquí en france 24
[Música]